it's a new week and that means new games
are coming out October is here
Halloween's right around the corner and
so is elite dangerous on xbox one let's
write that popular space adventure and
combat sim piloting a spaceship the
player explores realistic one-to-one
scale open-world galaxy based on the
real Milky Way the controls are highly
customizable so you should get them lock
down before you venture into the void
and whether using a flight stick or a
new xbox one controller you're going to
want to practice your docking pick your
faction on the six also this week we get
a tactical role-playing video game for
ps4 and the sixth in the disc aya series
disgaea five alliance of vengeance the
central story of the game is centered on
the idea of revenge the evil demon
Emperor void dark devastates numerous
neder worlds after coming to power with
the help of an army of over 1 million
soldiers known as the lost following
this the overlords of the netherworlds
under Boyde darks rule attempt to rise
up and take revenge head to the
netherworlds on the 6th now let's head
back to an era of awesome 80 style
cartoon graphics with transformers
devastation you get a campaign mode in a
challenge mode and are able to play as
five different Autobots given the
ability to swap between robot and car
form there's no multiplayer but it's ten
bucks shy of a full release price fifty
dollars so it's a little bit cheaper I'm
gonna be honest I was actually pretty
worried that this wasn't going to be
good and flew under my radar but it
looks pretty damn cool I'm going to find
out for sure on the six also this week
we get to enjoy the adventures of Nathan
Drake all over again with uncharted the
Nathan Drake collection gamespot's own
Mike McCarty said with uncharted two and
three Naughty Dog transcended Drake's
own small beginnings the Nathan Drake
collection is a first-hand account of
naughty Dog's growth as a storyteller
and this collection is the best way to
relive that history and witness its
transformation up close civilization
beyond Earth rising tide expansion comes
out this week adding new factions biomes
and units the major new features in this
expansion include a brand new diplomacy
system expanded aquatic gameplay
expanded exploration options and hybrid
affinities so there's a lot of new
features but something to focus on is
the freedom from pure specialization
rather than pursuing just one affinity
and then you're kind of locked into it
and punished if you move out of your
civilization you can take a hybrid
approach this way you can still unlock
special units and up
aids you can grab this expansion on the
9th finally rock band is finally making
its brand come back after almost three
years being hidden in your closet now
you can dust off those old guitars and
drum sets because they still work but
you will need a current gen console but
if you sold all your gear to thrift
stores game the charity or you just want
some new stuff there's plenty of new
instruments that you can pick up the
game will ship with more than 60
licensed songs here's a taste to some of
the various bands pretty much every
aspect of this game is what you remember
from the previous versions so if you're
okay with that same game same stuff and
people but newbies this is right up your
alley and you can bust a sick riff on
the 6th for further details into
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and they're subject to
change happy gaming
you